tiens alors vous êtes je vois des
publicités dans la presse
bedos au zénith et je te dire que je
trouve ça extraordinaire c'est cette
publicité parce que vous seriez à
l'olympia bordeaux mais bedos au zénith
ça prend un autre sens est à son zénith
il est à son zénith il ya que vous les
fachos édité au seuil
donc ça oui ça équilibre non mais parce
qu'ils prenons par exemple quelqu'un qui
est aussi très haut dans les sondages
mais ton mitterrand vous pourrez pas
faire par une publicité mitterrand au
zénith paraît très prétentieux oui j'ai
moi même chose des choses que mitterrand
hôtel mitterrand n'a pas encore accès
aux qui travaillent encore dans la
médiatisation oui ça c'est un métier bon
vous avez réuni 23 texte il ya des
textes anciens et ex nouveau des textes
que vous direz certains sur nous une ivg
pas quelqu'un elles sont été les
critères de vaud qui vous ont fait
choisir ses textes et par d'autres que
ce soit lisible que
que d'une certaine manière ça doivent
plus aux textes qu'à l'interprétation
il y à des sketchs puisque ces deux mots
français que nous employons généralement
qui sont très efficaces sur scène mais
qui ne sont pas là dedans parce que
justement il ya un accent italien ou
pieds-noirs cas et c'est la musique donc
2 du texte qui jouent alors que bon j'ai
essayé avec mes éditeurs de choisir oui
oui mais la chose qui va me faire rire à
l'écrit oui mais c'est ça les gêne en
même temps ouvert en fait - fc2c d'être
lus par une très belle jeune femme dans
un ordre à l'aéroport et qu'elle rit je
peux tu peux être accessible weeknd suis
là oui mais on ne peut pas s'empêcher
quand on vous lit c'est de se
représenter bedos en train de lire le
texte était obligatoire
je ne sais pas quand je fais le malin là
mais franchement je j'ai été un peu
je dis pas qu'on va forcer mais je veux
dire que l'on m'a convaincu car j'étais
j'étais sceptique parce que justement je
crois que ce soir je suis le seul à
n'avoir pas écrit pour être lu
oui massif on sait maintenant c'est fait
abbassi à propos d'ailleurs vous
d'habitude les gens oui parce l'aurait
il passe les cris ensuite l'oral vous
c'est le contraire bouffer de laura
avait depuis maintenant c'est l'écrit
mais c'est délicieux tous ces messieurs
vous savez votre bac
non ce n'est pas votre bac et vous même
mais oui oui moi non parce que le bac
c'est l'écrit d'abord et leur as long as
we échanger palais guy bedos à l'oral au
bac il a dû est extraordinaire non non
mais non mais j'ai rallongé pas été
jusque là d'épauler jeu vous allez à
l'oral de chantre de la rue blanche qui
tenait un cours de théâtre et c'est là
que je sais tu aimais université vous
dites et autres méchancetés sans
importance enfin sans importance pour
ceux qui sont victimes de vos miches ans
t on peut parler de soi sans importance
quand même on répond quand même ya de
tout là dedans oui mais ce que j'aime
c'est souvent et qui sont qui sont
vraiment des gamineries des blagues g
j'ai écrite comme ça
en voiture juste avant d'arriver au
théâtre sommes en m'inspirant de
l'actualité oui mais souvent des vous
faites deux ennemis d'un coup je dis
ceci rocard son modèle c'est mendès
france
mais enfin si on voulait être un peu
cruel on pourrait dire que rocard et
amendes est ce que francis huster est à
gérard philipe donc là vous faites deux
ennemis d'un coup 1
je suis pas sûr pensez pas non non non
francis huster est un bon acteur oui et
pas un regard non aucun est un bon
ministre
je trouve qu'il a beaucoup de mal ces
temps-ci et ne portait pas sur moi pour
l'accabler
est-ce que ce qui nous arrive parfois
quand même dans dans la vo petites
méchancetés vous dire que temps en temps
quand même là je vais trop loin
et oui ça vous arrivez alors qu est la
limite
comment savez vous que la limite c'est
faire de la peine à faire de la peine à
quelqu'un et à quelqu'un pour qui j'ai
au fond la sympathie mais que bon ben
voila je tape à côté quelques mois alors
ça ce ça m'est arrivé et je le regrette
puis à des gens il ya le pen dans je
m'en fous lui faire de la peine à le pen
mon fou il ya des gens dont je me fous
au contraire même ça me ferait plutôt
plaisir même de l'est
et les déranger un peu ouais mais voilà
mais je ne crois pas être un tueur non
plus non on s'en remet mais ce qui est
bien avec vous guy bedos et que vous dit
tout haut ce que les autres pensent tout
bas
oui c'est à dire que j'ai j'ai un surmoi
extrêmement léger oui je ne me contrôle
pas toujours c'est à dire que je vais au
bout de mes envies sans sens sans me
dire qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que ça va
me coûter
il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont peur ils
ont peur de s'exprimer
ils ont quelquefois des raisons d'avoir
peur d'ailleurs ce qu'on peut les virées
n'ont pas le droit de parler et je pense
que rôle d'un type comme moi c'est
peut-être quelquefois de d'être un haut
parleur et de de parler aussi pour les
autres une certaine façon je règle pas
des comptes personnels moi je prends les
gens qui sont mes cibles il n'y a pas
que ça dans le livre il ya aussi des
choses c'est pas beau il ya plein de
sketches williams qui sont des
observations de la vie quotidienne et
ces mêmes et pour ces petites choses là
ces petites phrases tout le monde en
fait les petites phrases les hommes
politiques justement maintenant ils
veulent faire drôle hein mais il est
déroutant parce que certains moments il
dit quand on lui dit effectivement vous
dit tout haut ce que les autres pensent
tout bas il dit bon j'aimais bien et
puis maintenant pas du tout parce qu'il
paraît qu'on dise à mme le pen veut oui
oui et ajoute je crois je cite de
mémoire et
il faut dire qu'il ya des gens quand ils
les cantines
quand ils disent tous qu'ils pensent
tout bas c'est tellement le site écrit
dont il a oublié quoi oublier oui oui
oui on fera soit un peu mieux vos textes
au zénith
mais ceci dit des choses qui sont pas
oui que même 10 tours voilà que même 10
tous est encore très bas et généralement
les gens se marrent alors je vous posais
une question la tour sa petite bête
pourquoi on ne s'aime pas tous comme ça
tous une belle question quoi vous voulez
me brancher sur un au pays que je vous
demande simplement pour mais que je lise
non pas du tout je veux pas de nom mais
c'est vrai c'est une belle réflexion
c'est notre candidat c'est pas du tout
préparés en plus c'est ça les gens
pensent souvent que que qu'à la
télévision ses copains et compagnie et
l'ail je sens bien ce qu'il veut il veut
que je dise un texte ah non non vous
n'êtes pas le nom mais je veux qu'on ne
s'aime pas à tous mais qu'on ne s'aime
plus les gens ne s'aiment plus c'est
lamentable mais l'exemple contre
français entre chrétiens entre blancs
alors comment vivez vous ces beaux
minable même pays de même villa même
quartier même famille parfois kivu poche
bruit avec ma propre mère ce n'est pas
vivable
à mon âge j'ai quasiment rompu avec
maman pour un stupide d accorder les
élections législatives coué ou 7 était
stable jeudi maman maman non répond
autant plus que voulez vous c'est une
personne que la fortune inquiète qui
faire elle s'échauffe chose à faire de
banques de comptes bloqués d'érosion
monétaire que sais-je tutorat pas contre
l'argent la bouche du moment moi aussi
je l'argent la banque
là vous ne savez pas ce qu'elle a le
toupet de me rétorquer oui mais moi j'en
ai beaucoup
ce admirable travail dans une insulte
mais ces acheteurs ou les podiums mais
leur nom ce qui comprend pas ce qui est
important c'est l'attaqué et parlez pas
de premier acte la wepad il n'y a pas
deux premiers chapitres mais il faut
qu'on sache tous les fans une des
attaques les plus célèbres et le texte
se trouve ici c'est
mais moi je peux pas le dire le débit de
bacs de vacances à marrakech
il exclut dans le début et bois non mais
vous le savez part que maintenant mais
non je sue plus là ces temps ci mais
n'attendez pas ce marrakech ça nous a
déçus c'est plein de l'arabe
voilà oui je sais que j'ai entendu ça
j'ai entendu dans un aéroport mais là
c'était pas bon et il parlait d'istanbul
bon je me suis dit que marrakech c'était
plus sa cause et mieux aux gens d'ici et
et le puits après bon ben on délire mais
sa part souvent d'une chose vraie ouais
ça part d'une phrase qu'on a entendu et
beaucoup de choses que j'ai que j'ai
volé aux gens évidemment c'est un
prédateur un voleur fait de la peine oui
vous êtes avez vu vous êtes allés avec
eux en algérie vous êtes retourne alger
notre fils nicolas oui oui et alors j'ai
vu et comment ça s'est passé
je veux pas que je dise mon libre et
d'eau produit tous ses fils président
fera ses juges mais c'est formidable
c'est dire classe et on voyage en
algérie
dommage le ciel était un peu gris
certains jours j'ai dit à mon fils
nicolas qui était avec moi tu vois mon
chéri du temps des français il faisait
beau oui mais moi je ne le dis pas bien
si très bien et non je ne dis pas que
vous le dites comme les gens vont lire
bah oui oui ça donc donc c'est vrai je
la fais oui parce que non sinon s'il
faut que je mette un disque à
l'intérieur du livre belgique oui au
fond chacun peut le dire au fond chacun
avec un avec des tests comme ça chacun
peut devenir chez nous est rappelé aux
médias c'est que c'est que bon des amis
téléphoner ça qui avait reçu le 10 mai
et qui m'ont dit qu'ils seraient pas
assez qu'ils riaient ans lisent encore
une fois c'est quelque chose qui me
flatte l'attend chez vous vous avez dit
à haute voix les textes de nom